[Musique]
et
c'était plus destinée
les jeunes thomas n'en
voulait voir qu'elle a de prime abord
notre groupe setec wallon des looks
s'était pas barbant accueilli wilks est
maintenant tholot un coup de jeunesse
[Musique]
c'est venu de famille ça c'était pas une
obligation c'est surtout une passion
rendre la binette micropole la bombe des
nanas à la base c'est juste une
répétition comme d'habitude nomades
on a fait quelque chose qui n'était pas
normal qu'ils n'étaient pas tradition
enfin pas traditionnel pas comme un
point commun on a décidé de filmer
centre hamad après c'est comme ça que la
machine est lancée on va dire
[Musique]
à